yeah what's the dish boy snapdragon
prime job missed on jesus sound as a
selfie sliding guiding ain't hiding hey
man tune in right now man to the bullet
cash show right now you about to see the
dog turn the [ __ ] up yeah
all right blackhead podcast special
guest in here
detroit's fine it's my guy's snapdog man
yeah king of energy mr own jesus
himself you know we sliding glide man we
ain't hiding man what's the deal man
energy indeed i don't know if you need
the red bull yeah we're gonna crack that
in a minute yeah let's start off with
the fact you have four phones the show
why for phones that's a lot i have two
phones [ __ ] man just [ __ ] just dealing
with this business that we in is like
[ __ ] so can we designate each phone like
what's each phone for like ain't none of
them no whole phone you know some [ __ ]
if you haven't already little whole
phone so none of these are the phone for
the hoes nah i know ain't no hoes this
right here is the this i call this the
industry phone okay like this this the
phone with just the most important phone
okay with all the industry people and
everything this one right here i just
call this the little shoot em up right
here right here you know people who are
who be wanting the number but i really
don't want to have contact with you i
give you this number okay this one right
here is crazy don't nobody got this
number but my mama that's just the mama
phone yeah and then this one right here
this like the game phone right here
the gang phone yeah
so that's the phone that doesn't exist
yeah because what is a game
no yeah you know i'm talking you know
yeah the fellas the homies
homies you know what they got going on
you got to be careful throwing that word
out there man yeah the family
got to be careful yeah yeah the show
speaking of uh i was in detroit um
for about a week
not for about a week for an actual week
a few weeks ago and uh man love your
city man my first time there
and we were very much
in the uh hood yeah we was around bro
yeah yeah it get like that man but
honestly bro i felt i i didn't you know
i feel like uh
coming away from that trip i was like
man i feel like detroit has a bad uh nat
like like reputation yeah everybody
everybody think like if you come to
detroit we gonna do this right
really detroit man we love everybody bro
long as you ain't on that [ __ ] or
disrespecting the city then we ain't got
no we ain't got no problem with you
what's the one thing about detroit to
like all these other cities like
everybody separate you know what i'm
saying but like in detroit like even if
we is separate the moment you do some
[ __ ] the one important person in
that city we gonna all come together on
your head now one thing about these
tricks they're going to stick together
on your head like well i just saw uh
rest in peace the hutch right yeah
that's the jeweler and and uh just did
any piece i ever got in my life
he uh got someone shot him right it was
just kind of random what happened yeah
i don't know the story behind that [ __ ]
but this is it's [ __ ] up because it's
like everybody go to hutch no matter
people who don't know hutch was a big
jeweler in big jewels kind of like the
jeweler right the number one jewel in
detroit ain't nobody [ __ ] the hutch
like he's the number one jewel
like i used to be in high school like
man when i'm doing what the [ __ ] i'm
doing like when i get some money [ __ ]
that's what i'm going to [ __ ] hutch
like you're going to get your bus from
hutch you're going to get your chain
from her and here he a lovely dude man
he show love and respect man he loved
the city right now the city so the city
just took a big loss with that [ __ ] i
noticed everyone was posting them yeah
man [ __ ] [ __ ] up about that one yeah
it's it's so like because we always hear
about like this big divide between the
east side and the west side of detroit
yeah um
how much of that is
real and how much of it is like a little
actually it's actually back in the day
it was bigger you know what i'm saying
you really couldn't get to east side and
west side [ __ ] to [ __ ] with each other
like by any means now
we all [ __ ] with each other like me
the east side i'm a west side [ __ ]
eastside show me so much [ __ ]
lil you think i was like from the east
like my [ __ ] lou vez peasy danny
[ __ ] man the let's go on with the
eastside boys man and they face ray like
they are taking over right now too so
it's like they putting on for the city
too so now it's like we all
understanding the assignment and we
coming together and [ __ ] understanding
like there's not no real beef now if you
got real beef behind that [ __ ] then
people leave that alone but it's like if
it's some she he say she said or [ __ ]
[ __ ] yo [ __ ] [ __ ] man we looking over
that man come on man [ __ ] that [ __ ] we
about to make this hit song and we're
gonna stun on that hoe
because it does feel like right now the
east side has a lot of the big more
bigger artists nationally but i felt i
feel like uh early on like we think
about uh you know doughboy
those are all west side guys so i feel
like it kind of and and i was talking to
uh i forget who was telling me
that the west side is more
like the player [ __ ] i gave it to you to
break down west side
west side [ __ ] you have some of the
west side west side is more flashy
meaning as in
and it is it's different now because we
everybody getting everybody's getting
money he's saying
back then it'd be like a west side [ __ ]
go spend all that money on this outfit
to look good for the hoes and go out
that day but don't it's broke as [ __ ]
right that eastside [ __ ] don't have
that that jargon shoot on looking dirty
as here with that bankroll [ __ ] hustle
you know what i'm saying he said i got a
lot of hustler [ __ ] both sides got the
hustle in it but now it's like we all
just get into the paper nah
what i did uh eat well listen we went to
a bunch of different restaurants out
there but this uh coney island thing
yeah we went to like three or four of
them and i was like man this is some
real
because they're like you gotta you gotta
go to a coney island yeah too you gotta
get a cold coney dog or some chili tea
fried chicken pita what was the name of
that place we went to um
we went to a few but there was one that
first day with the drive-through
it was on eight mile
it was right by that liquor store
anyway we um
yeah so i got the detroit coney the the
hot dog the detroit style coney or
whatever but just in general like the
coney island thing is very much like
they got breakfast
they got everything omelettes in the
whole wings they got literally whatever
you want and the hoes love it cause
imagine they open all day so when you
leaving from the club
two in the morning on that weekend man
that line filled the [ __ ] up like
[ __ ] want chicken pitas
[ __ ] snacks and [ __ ] i got
club sandwiches they got anything you
could [ __ ] literally everything
everything on the menu for sure and then
like we went to uh
i think papa's is that papa's that's on
the east side we were there wassada baby
and uh
i had a um
they had cake we had cake there we had a
goddamn patty milk and i'll see if you
should've brought you on the west side
when you you should took you to fat boys
a crab house that [ __ ] land like that
you know where we did go um
baby tron took us to
a place that's like a
uncle joe's something joe's
it's like uh it's like raising canes but
the detroit style of raising canes that
[ __ ] was so it was on the west side it
was in now it was kind of like uh
yeah it felt like it was like kind of by
the airport low-key it was like okay
it was nice though and then we went to
original pancake house okay yeah that
[ __ ] was gas yeah yeah we got some [ __ ]
man i [ __ ] with detroit man it was a
vibe for sure love the mgm there man
yeah mgm is nicer than one in vegas man
what
what maybe you're a type of [ __ ] going
down you'll see a whole [ __ ] fight
break out right then and there and these
get knocked out [ __ ] i like it
ain't even happen like that's just
detroit for you and just beautiful black
women everywhere the show we do we
definitely got some beautiful black and
woman we got them on everyone you know
they and they pop out when it's time for
a concert see right now they popped out
because it's summer right so you're
gonna catch them downtown river walk or
that but like if you got [ __ ]
lure baby or a little boozy or somebody
coming in the city ooh
all you gotta do is just drive on time
i'm telling you listen i went to a tech
nine concert and that was not the type
of people that
there was a lot of [ __ ] white trash
in there there's some crazy
[ __ ] in there he got a crazy
face bro now the tech 9 show was very
much a different type of uh
detroit white trash hits different bro
yeah
yeah
that's crazy because i used to [ __ ]
check
watching that concert
i fully understood eminem now i was like
this is where these these are his people
this is how yeah they ain't take you
down hey mom
you know i went there myself oh yeah
we went to the trailer park and
everything yeah yeah i was like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is crazy like yeah i went to
evidence trailer park and that [ __ ] was
real life like damn this whole grew up
in this [ __ ] place there was like
some toothless lady outside watering her
water in the grass she's watering her
dirt one folk would be tripping get off
my [ __ ] bro that trailer you've been in
that trailer park i ain't been in there
yeah
it's maybe because i'm from there it'd
be like man i ain't yeah no i was
definitely but i definitely [ __ ] with
him trick trick race five nine shout out
to the boy shots on him
i was like man i gotta hit up trick
trick if i'm coming to detroit i don't
want to be one of those no no no no no
no it doesn't do the checking you gotta
hit up me well i hit you up as well yeah
but no trick or tell you he gave me that
are you are you the new uh keep the key
the key finder the no fly zone but um we
don't we don't we don't push it like you
know what i'm saying it's i'm
documenting that trick trick to tell you
itself i actually got a documentary with
him telling tell him how he gave me the
keys to the city but it's not i don't
know like a [ __ ] like running city like
it's like it's just it's like i'm a gate
founder of detroit like a [ __ ]
can't overlook that the young especially
with the young crew like i'm the [ __ ]
who brought everybody to the city like
they very first time i'm bringing them
to the city making sure they straight
they get hung they get to their show and
have fun that's all it is to it man but
now it's like you know what i'm saying
we got the easton west that's that's
doing a thing so you know everybody can
bring anybody in you know what i'm
saying yeah is uh because the uh
origination of the no-fly zone i think
it started to get kind of more national
attention when the rick ross thing
happened at the radio show and that's
the thing like people was taking you
know trick message wrong like it wasn't
no no hating [ __ ] like he was just
saying like [ __ ] if my city can book
y'all cause y'all always come to the d
we always get all y'all feed that y'all
if
we can do that bro show love to the city
show love to the artists stop just
coming in and coming out treating us
like we some whole ass [ __ ] cause we
used to get overlooked you know what i'm
saying now look everybody want to come
to the d everybody want to wear buffs
everybody want to be a part of the
culture of detroit everybody want an
artist from detroit on a song's night
that's all we was trying to do is push
the message like don't overlook it it's
kind of crazy like you guys definitely
have um
i think it's detroit or memphis in terms
of just the show cities and hip-hop
definitely right now is detroit in
memphis definitely and you can't
overlook that
what up y'all hey we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our partners
the presenting sponsor of the
bootleghead podcast our family at odd
socks man they're dropping so much heat
at odd socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddssocksofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
we got more for the bait phase right
going crazy you know what i'm saying
memphis you got i think baby money just
got locked up with free baby money or is
he ideal i didn't see that but i i think
he was accurate off the internet i know
that he had to jump off a tour he was
because he was on the babyface radar but
he's on a qc yeah um i mean peasy yeah i
watched that [ __ ] grow up
i [ __ ] with his brother when he was in
high school shot a baby yeah vazo was
going crazy yeah they're going crazy
everyone forgot the chips i ain't gonna
lie i ain't even figure that out until i
think the post was chewing him with the
chits when you do that [ __ ] and then go
to the movie man that's some smart
marketing [ __ ] bro yeah we were hanging
out with him shooting the final scenes
of his movie acting and [ __ ] yeah he's
like [ __ ] man you could i remember man
it's crazy because like i remember when
he was on motown and they just did like
something they weren't doing right yeah
as soon as he got released he started
because that's about his vision you know
what i'm saying and i ain't see his
vision and i'm not looking at him he
independent he's taking over doing his
[ __ ] time running it up man
fact what is it about detroit you think
that like it's finally y'all's time
right now because it feels like finally
because you guys have always been active
and always been doing your thing and
there's always been a scene there but in
terms of just commercial timing yeah
that's all it is and i and i look at it
like this it's perfect timing right now
like if we would have got it back then
it probably would have got watered down
like you know what i'm saying it's
better now you know what i'm saying like
you got the flint rappers you got yeah
shout out to flint yeah shout out to
armstrong
you know what i'm saying you got all
them so it's like all this [ __ ] going
crazy right now so it was it was just
timing bro it was time cause we been had
it like if you really look at everybody
who popping on
it was a time when they first came out
they was popping like right now like me
i'm working my [ __ ] back up like i when
i first came out my way was so big i
didn't know what the [ __ ] to do with it
because rapping was my dream and then
i'm like one of the founders of the
drill scenes from detroit you got dicks
and yeah jordan and then they go me deep
pots you know what i'm saying we the we
the [ __ ] of the drill scene
like now i'm doing all that type of
music but that's what we use [ __ ]
with
what happened to your ig
man heartbroken that's that's the rp
date that's august 24th i'll never
forget that because you were dming me
and i didn't even know yeah i didn't
even see it because it just and i hate
that [ __ ] cause it's like i'll be dm and
i'll be dming all the people man and
it's like
i can't get mad at them when they
overlook it like like me just followed
me
and he unfollowed me i'm like what the
[ __ ] is you on he like snap i thought
this [ __ ] was fake [ __ ] this this show
page i'm like yeah cause i just vanished
i don't know i guess when instagram had
that disabled when they was taking
everybody's [ __ ] it may end up taking
miles but i literally didn't do nothing
like it was it was just crazy you
weren't getting violated or nothing man
i wasn't doing [ __ ] like my violations
came from instagram first when the guns
and all that i ain't post guns in years
i don't do that [ __ ] no mo so like for
them to just take my [ __ ] down it was
just like yeah you bullying you going
against i'm like what are you talking
about my last post was me giving
book bags out to the kids shout out to
my brother that boy was giving the boot
bags out to the kids to go back to
school before my fight and they checked
it my guy freddie gibbs has had uh
10 instagram pages in the last year they
took his official one down and he just
keeps making new ones and then they
finally i can't keep doing that he's a
trooper i ain't you know i think he's i
think he's just throwing the hat in i
think he's just like i'm on twitter
[ __ ] like like i ain't gonna lie that
that ain't that [ __ ] hard bro i had
almost a million bro like
and i worked that was my core fan base
right there like so just to get that
[ __ ] snatched away from you it was like
you got to be hard like that [ __ ] worse
than getting you got them jury snack you
know take the jewelry yeah you can go
[ __ ] [ __ ] up or prevent [ __ ] from
doing that you can't do nothing like it
just you can't can you can you get like
uh
like will they like re-verify you or
because i'm trying to get re-verified
right now cause it's like at this point
i don't need to give i ain't tripping
about the page no more because when the
page got took it was doing my fight so i
was stressing and i'm thinking like i'm
like damn bro like i'm [ __ ] like
[ __ ] i gotta start back over but then i
really said to myself like now i don't
have to start back over everybody in the
world everybody in the industry ain't
gonna say everybody in the world most of
the world and everybody in the industry
know who snapdog is right so it's like i
ain't no new artist i just gotta they
gotta find me so now they just are
finding me back and now i gotta get the
blue check this cause this is a lot of
fake pages of me so that blue check
don't let them know that it's me
so you i feel like you had like i think
i might have
[ __ ] i think i reached out to you in
like 2018 or 2019 probably 2018 when i
first saw you uh start to kind of like
pop up all my [ __ ] um
and it felt like you kind of like there
was like a period in which you kind of
stopped dropping music for a little bit
two years
yeah so what happened i just basically i
just i had to learn the game man because
it's like like i said i was getting so
my wave was so big and you feel me i'm
dealing with all these features and all
this i didn't know nothing about [ __ ]
like before i got linked with empire
like i i really was just i linked do a
song we do the video drop it i didn't
like i got [ __ ] with a little baby the
[ __ ] was even me and dirk i never put
none of that on apple music i didn't
know nothing about no streaming
platforms all i knew was to just shoot a
video i'm a street [ __ ] right rapping
with my dream all i knew shoot a video
drop that [ __ ] and that
[ __ ] go up you feel me but then
when i got to learning [ __ ] i'm like oh
yeah let me sit back and learn and then
at the same time i was in a boxing ring
too you know what i'm saying so i'm like
i had to get focused real quick but i
never stopped working though like i
stayed in the studio every day
how serious
okay for people who don't know because
you've
from a surface level fans perspective i
know you've
not threatened but you've called out any
rapper to fight any rapper i don't give
a [ __ ] who you any rapper that you ever
see threw some gloves on
and hit the mix ain't gonna say rapper
any celebrity does you see threw some
gloves on in the midst i said come on
let's set the fighter you can't say
don't nobody knows that dog you can't
say it ain't gonna sell out like it's
gonna sell out so house how uh
i guess like how serious did your boxing
career actually get to like the highest
point that it actually oh i'm actually
the first rapper to ever in history
gopro i'm actually a pro fighter which
is my hand's license but the thing is is
i did that first pro fight knocked his
ass out in the fourth round it was a
good fight well no easy fight people see
the video and they'd be like oh snap you
was fighting somebody who was oh if you
was at that fight you knew like there
was no easy fight like i had [ __ ] the
room was so sold out like saw the baby
was there too the room was so [ __ ]
filth like
people were scared people was like snap
you had me nervous for a minute bro you
was letting him hit you i'm like
brother's boxing my [ __ ] like let's
check y'all can't look at me like floyd
you feel my checkers man it's boxing but
we got the knockout or whatever but
that [ __ ] definitely it is it's serious
cause you gotta you gotta tune in and
tune everything out bro like especially
i didn't go fight somebody off the
street or a weak [ __ ] i know i
can beat i want to go fight an
undefeated [ __ ] since you're pro
if you fight someone like a street fight
can't you nope is it i can whoop your
head so it they they won't like they
won't look at you like you're you're
fighting somebody with deadly weapons
yeah no you putting your hands on me
okay i don't know
i get to defend myself
for sure you should get in and spar with
uh d smoke
yeah whatever they want to do brother
[ __ ] gonna make one who that's that how
big is he bro
he's shorter he's like uh
he's probably wider than you like he's
more probably how much he weight like
i'm 123.
he weighs more than you he probably
weighs like 150. 160. hey i'm not ain't
nothing my coaches when he let me do
that but i mean just just just a
fun because he's special
good guy you're a good you can
definitely we definitely can just he
just bought um him and g parico just
bought uh the broadway boxing gym in l.a
no we i definitely we just sparring we
we do that all day yeah i swear with
everybody that i was in i was training
with for my fight he wanted to fight uh
he was talking about man i want to fight
ddg
he's like
dude because he smokes like you he's
like like he's been boxing for like 12
years or some [ __ ] yeah seriously yeah
he's like been around the world in
boxing yeah i ain't gonna lie like if
schmoe should go after jake paul ddg it
ain't no no no no he i i he wants to but
you know i think
jake paul's trying to fight [ __ ]
you know yeah floyd mayweather
he won't floyd you know that's a good
payday it's a good payday and then you
can't you can't blame him though because
he came in one year may what 44 million
bro he made morton what the [ __ ] real
boxers the thing about jake paul is um
he made people pay attention to the
sport again for sure he gave he gave
boxing a bigger light besides uh devin
hayney devonte davies yeah well even
even those guys like
generic
like people on the street they don't
they don't know about javonte davis you
know what i'm saying like yeah
they're not they're they're they're
going to see you a boxing fan to really
like buy that pay-per-view as opposed to
like
jake paul you're like yo [ __ ] this guy
and i went to one of the [ __ ] fights
jake paul yeah i actually brought my
brother out montana he had a knockout on
that card too his life changed after
that fight when i say bro i brought him
out on television and i'm bringing him
out to the ring and i'm performing my
song and when i just walked out and seen
thought i'm [ __ ] people bro i'm like
man this this white boy that's smart as
[ __ ]
like they was going crazy
at least he's taking it seriously no he
do take that's one thing i've been in
his crib you know what i'm saying shout
out to jay his barber like man he got me
and jake close and i've been in his crib
you know what i'm saying and that boy
take he take that [ __ ] here he's
training three times a day so i'm saying
be different if like he was just like um
playing around with it playing around or
like boot game or yeah like ah knock his
ass out he keep running for me bro boom
gang he just he's still what's his name
john gabbana that's the name he he he he
father god i sent his ass right up there
with a knockout for the show he keep
running for me man like he challenged
him man i call all these [ __ ] out bro
did you fight blue face yes i will fight
blue face and i [ __ ] with blue face and
what like i'll be at wax studio i'll be
you know i got music with true chord at
my boy i i'll fight blue face on some
like let's just make the bag [ __ ] dude
we can go straight to the studio after
that you know what i'm saying
but one thing i can say about blue face
he can't reach from the beginning now
that [ __ ] i mean [ __ ] to me okay
from the beginning when i seen him fight
to now that he's training he got way
[ __ ] better he got way better he
learned it he i see that he learned how
to work his jab because he got reached
and he know how to keep a [ __ ]
this is me i'm gonna get under there you
gotta keep his distance from all them
wild [ __ ] he'd be surrounding them
he'd be going through some [ __ ] i'd be
like no i can't eat i can't eat i can't
do [ __ ] with this
with the mom
with the toothless girl the mom and the
sister yeah then she get in the face
teddy don't like i ain't gonna i don't
want no [ __ ] like that bro bro i don't
want that bro
she stole his car drive across the
country and you took her back
and then i from what i've i think she uh
cut herself and then wrote her name on
his wall with her blood or some wild
[ __ ] shorty shorty out her [ __ ] yo yeah
like i don't want that that's like
that's somebody that never leave you
alone mind you like a level of crazy
like that the draw has got to be insane
insane
[Music]
i'm running i'm running from that [ __ ]
bro anymore i [ __ ] try to do some
[ __ ] like that i gotta run i don't like
that toxic [ __ ] bro i don't i don't
focus speaking of toxic i mean you do
you have a lot of children yeah how many
uh how many kids and how many baby moms
six
damn yeah i don't got baby mama drama
you don't have any yeah no because i
ain't [ __ ] them boots like having
that progress he's still [ __ ] well
that's what uh southside i just had
south side last week and you know he's
got uh four baby mamas one of his young
miami from city girls and he was like i
said what's the key to co-parenting and
he said don't [ __ ] your baby i'm [ __ ]
bro because when you [ __ ] you you we
you re activating that goddamn feeling
it's the feeling and it's like [ __ ]
your baby mama's gone they already know
they can they know you they know exactly
who you is so they know what type of
buttons they can push and they'll take
that [ __ ] any of your baby mom is
friends with each other all of them is
so it's kind of they all get along
because at the end of the day i ain't
[ __ ] y'all at the end of the day it's
like something happened to me y'all
gonna make sure my kids yeah and they're
like and
you know when you have those kids you
want to make sure all of them are close
with each other all my kids close like
it'd be funny because i was like
sometimes like back then i just had to
go like i got like five cars so back
then i used to have to take both of my
cars to go pick all my kids up like i
have my boy driver one i'm driving once
jesus
now we got enough seats now we got
trucks
i got to get the [ __ ] third row
gotta get to the point they even see it
i mean one time my daughter like she
want to go to disney world i'm like all
right we gonna go she's talking how are
you gonna feel this all in your car
yeah but i know it's a blessing you
gotta get a sprinter just for the kids
yeah it's a blessing man i ain't gonna
lie about my kids it's would keep me
going and keep me motivated because if
it weren't for them i probably would
have said [ __ ] life i'd be definitely be
in the jail or probably you know in some
other situation yeah definitely um
give me some like uh because you know
you're obviously out here in l.a now
but uh
what is the politics like when because
obviously there's crips there's bloods
in detroit are the politics as because
out here they're pretty intense they get
complicated
it ain't it ain't like it ain't like the
the detroit ain't that that's cuz this
[ __ ] originated from there right so most
of [ __ ] that do gang bang out
there they it's it's chorus [ __ ] and
then a lot of you got a lot of these
[ __ ] who
they they saying that they this and that
and they really like fast doing that
[ __ ] but when you come to l.a you're
gonna have that right [ __ ] who's
going you know what i'm saying gonna
check it and make sure you is and if you
ain't [ __ ] you're gonna have a problem
with that [ __ ] see me
detroit really more so about hoods the
blocks
sound like i'm from west side i'm from
plymouth which is p rock you know what
i'm saying so that's my hood like it's
not no gang thing or nothing like that
people used to think i was a hoover or
whatever because i wore orange and we
had orange flags
like my watch but we wear orange for my
twin brother who passed away with his
name bronco
he liked drinking orange pop so we wear
orange to represent him and [ __ ] real
name broncos so the bronco logo that's
what we got and it's like [ __ ] like even
out here like people in l.a like they
respect it because they they know like
this behind a person this ain't no
gang [ __ ] he ain't doing none of that he
representing his twin brother and who
wouldn't do that of course i went to the
uh a store on the west side a liquor
store they had pizza
there was a pizza in there chicken it
was a giant liquor store yeah
the best part about this store i've
never seen this before they had the
bootleg weed bags
[Music]
hold on yo [ __ ] no oh you talking about
just the bootleg no like the [ __ ] the
boot like you could buy each bag was a
dollar like you know that you could get
you a cookie's bag you're getting yeah
gary payton bag runs yeah yeah at the
liquor store they just got the in the
back corner they were just like detroit
detroit home with a hustler so you could
buy
any weed bag and put whatever funky ass
weeds you got in it yeah like it's dead
and act like yourself but them [ __ ]
know you know i don't smoke weed i don't
do that you know what i'm saying i don't
do [ __ ] i don't smoke i don't drink i
don't pop no pill don't do nothing well
shout out to you like nothing at all you
don't smoke i don't do [ __ ] did you ever
smoke uh i only smoked the blood with
snoop
that [ __ ] put me down
definitely like i'm like hell no i can't
i can't i'm king of energy i came up
[ __ ] be i'm trying to yeah i can't do
that off no damn blunt bro be like this
like mine all right like you feel me i
know i like to be turnt bro like [ __ ]
like to be turning like my [ __ ] bobby
schmurder
yeah he's a lot yeah bobby ain't got
[ __ ] on me
um
yeah it was wild cause i was like damn
they really out here bootlegging weed
and you know uh what can you give me
like um
in your opinion why there's such a
correlation between san francisco
oakland the bay and detroit it feels
like y'all are cousins though man this
is it's to be honest with you
the it's cause ganzi bro
like guys he really stamped that [ __ ]
guys he was the first [ __ ] to
really come to the d and pick up
upcoming artists and give us a platform
to be heard on and to be seen and to be
honest with you like the first
[ __ ] from the d who really took
that away and went crazy with that [ __ ]
with oakland and the bay and all that
wood band gang lonnie my eyes oh autumn
[ __ ] like they really often not them
dogs too like they went to that
[ __ ] was going crazy like
chilling out shows yeah and it made guns
you tuned in a little bit more to the
city and then you got peasy you got all
them and then you got me you know what
i'm saying and it just it just got the
groin because guys you really be out
with the people he coming to the hood
you know what i'm saying he's coming out
there seeing how the culture is and it's
like we don't got nobody who important
like that doing that these labels they
just see you from the internet and dm
you want to fly you out no because now
now it's funny because uh
it feels like now everybody's trying to
sign someone from detroit for sure for
sure and everything is your label hey
everybody you got you got yo gotti with
with with dubs
you got [ __ ] qc 342 doug yeah
it's a rough man yeah man it'd be crazy
man when you when you [ __ ] with them
when you wanna when you got a record bro
you a rapper bro that [ __ ] is real hard
bro cause it's like anything you gotta
move real swift because anything
on anything that's going wrong they're
gonna put it on you and i'm gonna [ __ ]
with you any in that car you know what
i'm saying they're gonna put it on you
just give you the rapper they want to
get that money you know what i'm saying
you know it seems like now i mean
they've always kind of used lyrics
against people but it seems like they're
really really like making it an
assertive effort to because at the end
of the day it's like
why the [ __ ] y'all gonna use
that [ __ ] with rappers but charlie ain't
doing that with r and b singers or
[ __ ] who act in movies yeah
y'all ain't doing that with playing a
murderer on tv that don't mean they're a
[ __ ] murderer like damn like we just
we art we just talking playing around
like you know what i'm saying we just
basically talking about what we see in
movies the end of the day it's art this
is art right we're painting that picture
and y'all using this [ __ ] putting people
especially when these [ __ ] is
getting out of this and they being
successful they giving back to their
community you feel me they definitely
want to come when you're successful and
you know what i'm saying free the whole
wide seal man that's my family bro thug
dude gonna broke hard on bro pay for my
eyes bro
he paid for your eyes yeah i got the
laser [ __ ] on my eyes like i couldn't
even see real for real
i had to [ __ ] that vision he paid for
your lasik uh surgery yeah
yeah yeah but i got i was one of the
whole time i've been out here until just
like until he went to jail with the
everyday dude i was done every day bro
like real family recently yeah we was
watching the game this was last year
last summer he played for we watching
the game and i couldn't see the game
like tv was like this close and i'm like
hey what's the scope like [ __ ] you
can't see i'm like hell no he told his
manager like go get go get his glasses
like reading glasses from from the car i
put him on i see how i'm seeing that he
like oh yeah yo i [ __ ] up like mine
i'mma set you with his appointment
tomorrow just be there and then the
doctors all that i'm talking about [ __ ]
a top top top notch [ __ ]
they're like yeah you ready to i say
what you mean ready do what they like to
get your [ __ ] done i'm like [ __ ] yeah i
need to tell me how much it costs like
no it's already covered jeffrey covered
it
oh yeah man that that man a good man bro
like
it's it's nobody perfect but man that
man was close to perfect in my eyes bro
the way that that man take care of his
people bro and you know what i'm saying
he's still able to be humble and just
how he is bro just
it's it's [ __ ] up to see that [ __ ]
happen bro like that's yeah somebody who
like employees employs a lot of people
in the city who obviously gives back and
yeah um
except it's just yes it's crazy yo what
up man we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our good folks
at blue chew that's right go to
bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you were like
20. you know what i mean well listen
bluechu it is the wave uh how about this
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis getting delivered right to
your door in a chewable form in discreet
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online
zero awkward visits to the doctor's
office zero you go online you sign up
with the promo code bootleg that's right
bootleg when you check out you will get
the first month for free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars on shipping and
you're gonna get one month's supply of
blue chew all right and you're gonna be
[ __ ] like you were [ __ ] never
[ __ ] before your dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's going to be
rocked up rocked up and sucked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com
and use that promo code bootleg and get
your first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechoo.com let's get back to the
interview how did you end up initially
building that relationship with him duke
i was close with duke and uh
the car dude like
and it was crazy because still been
watching me but when i my when i first
came out a lot of people were scared to
[ __ ] with me because i was tripping like
them guns and all that running from the
police all that all that [ __ ] was real i
ain't abused his ass like did you ever
pay for the police no [ __ ] i definitely
couldn't afford that [ __ ] i was broke
and dirty you [ __ ] [ __ ] we taking off
for real on these [ __ ] but you
know what i'm saying a lot of people was
it was scared to [ __ ] with me because
it's like bro this [ __ ] wow bro like
you know what i'm saying
thugger used to say lil [ __ ] and go
ghost like
like it'll be a video of me and my mom
dudes because everybody everybody know
me and my mom dude's got a good
relationship so we'd be turnt up on ig
to one of my sons and he'd be he had
comment and just go ghost i'd be in this
thing like man
bro and then he called dukes like hey
man tell snap to pull up the gunner
birthday party bro
he like i'm [ __ ] with you and the
more that
i was around him he was teaching me the
game like one thing about me
i'm not no fan [ __ ] like like you know
how [ __ ] are you gonna have
them phones out and all that like i
ain't no [ __ ] if i'm gonna be around a
celebrity i'm quiet hey now i'm trying
to soak the game what can you teach me
what do you see me doing
where i can you know polish up on that
you know what i'm saying to come better
and it's like doug he literally told me
like ain't nothing you could do snack
you got everything that a [ __ ]
won't everybody love you all that
usually i get right with god bro
and when he said it i'm like what the
[ __ ] you mean get right to god like
i be praying
like that all that but i knew what he
meant like get right with god and get
your life together my [ __ ] get your
[ __ ] together chill that dumb [ __ ] the
[ __ ] up yeah yeah when i did that it was
like just doors just got to opening up
for me bro wait so you were in uh
you were in high speed chasing this on
video man i was in [ __ ] oh that type
of [ __ ] is all on the internet
like it was all just oh it was just like
meaning like okay we shooting a video
and it's like we shooting this with
jerry too
and we shooting a video and i got guns
out you know what i'm saying in the in
one of the one of the clips i'm like i
ain't gonna lie i didn't give a [ __ ] bro
i really was just showing my lights and
one of the clips i get to shoot in the
gun for real but i'm shooting at a
bandeau crib so i get to shoot in a gun
and one of the neighbors called the
police like on some slick [ __ ] so we all
out there with the gun man all you see
is cause it's like i always have people
on the corner they like hook hook hook
run
everybody else ran
like and the police came and it my
cameraman caught it and that [ __ ] went
up so you shot uh because in detroit
there's a lot of abandoned houses yeah
yeah yeah that's right it's crazy um
the only place i've been to that
reminded me of detroit just the way it
looks and as far as just like how the
houses are how there's like empty lots
yeah definitely it's buffalo it's a lot
of it's a shout out to buffalo it's
definitely a lot of band though it's
like you have some like my hood we call
it the ghost town at first that
[ __ ] used to look pretty mm-hmm
but then when everything got the falling
and what do you think like what was it
that happened that kind of because i i
uh
like
obviously like you said i'm sure where
you lived before it was
yeah houses were active people were
living there there was you know what
people just it's just people losing
their jobs people can't afford [ __ ] like
the community just just how the world is
like look what we're living in right now
bro like look what's going on right just
[ __ ] up you got the gas prices gas
prices going on you got [ __ ] active
war [ __ ] going on
you got covey like like what the [ __ ]
like anything where you about to be you
got [ __ ] rp to the kids you got
people shooting up these innocent kids
man come on bro like
the world just are just crazy right now
bro it's something in the air bro do you
because you're from michigan and
michigan is an open carry state right
so it's very
uh
you can
do do you think that's a good thing hell
no no none of us often carry that's
that's just a way of catching your ass
up
open carry ain't good cause we detroit
[ __ ] you gotta detroit [ __ ]
dude you have a female in the line at a
gas station paying for her [ __ ] her gun
on her head she's showing it you got a
[ __ ] who gonna come snatch that
[ __ ] off your head what you
gonna do
nothing can't do nothing yeah he gone
you got my first hood take your gun take
your clip out your gun you better have
one up top and you gotta realize with
the open carry you can't do all that
when you get in that car you gotta put
that [ __ ] in the glitter
department clipboard whatever the rules
is man by the time a [ __ ] robbie
will try to do something you [ __ ]
my boy was saying that uh
when the cops run his plates they see
that he's got a gun so they leave him
alone
i don't know how accurate that is
because i don't be in them i don't know
i don't be in a police car so i don't
know how accurate that [ __ ] is but they
be knowing cause there have been times
where you'd be on the block and my
homies they got cpl
like i uh make sure they got them
[ __ ] so we good they pull right up
they jump right out
and they already know you got the gun on
you you know what i'm saying
but it's it's [ __ ] you got to protect
ourselves bro so what's next for you man
man right now i got taking no chances
out i just dropped that that's like i
ain't gonna lie like that's my top tier
work that's my best work you know i'm
saying i got zombo producing mk
we got uh show out uh man we got
hollywood that's that's uh doing the
beat
man and it's just it's just that tape
right there it really opened it's really
opening a lot of doors up from me right
now because everybody was so skeptical
about all he do is yell like all he do
is yell all day and rap about drill
music but that right there i actually
show my versatility like now i can get
on yeah i mean i told you i heard some
of your unreleased stuff when you were
working with the ethica guys and it was
way different than the [ __ ] that you
probably know yeah and like some people
like people be asking me like what type
of do you like type of music do you like
more like i like doing them like one
thing about snapdog when you hear
snapdog you either gonna hear about
murder or you're gonna hear about pain
you know what i'm saying what's going on
in a life or what i'm seeing or what i'm
hearing about or what stories that my
peoples have been through i put it to
where i can understand it so other
people can relate it but that's one
thing that you always know i'm not the
i'm not the barfer bar rapper i'm not
the [ __ ] who's gonna have you
twerking you know what i'm saying for
the [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
live too i'm the [ __ ] you want
to go with your baby daddy ass
or you want to go with a [ __ ] ass you
know what i'm saying it's going to get
you turned i'm about i'm all about
energy bro like i tell [ __ ] all day you
got rap me i ain't tripping i'm about
energy my [ __ ] but if you get on the
same stage as me you [ __ ] if you go on
the show and i do i go on the show
you're [ __ ] and i knew that i couldn't
be [ __ ] with when man designer was on
the same stage and i did that [ __ ] and
that's one [ __ ] who got some energy oh
god i remember he would do this thing
where he tossed the mic in the air and
man bro that [ __ ]
what man like the [ __ ] the [ __ ] did
the show and ran out the front door of
the building bro like it was a sold out
event he ran through the crowd ran out
the door i'm like bro what the [ __ ] is
he on like oh [ __ ] i had to top that
[ __ ] i jumped all off the [ __ ] oh type
me boy you have any [ __ ] up [ __ ] you
ain't my outfit for me
but
yeah i'm all about king energy man so
it's like i just dropped taking no
chances out new instagram snapdog
underscore 27. uh i'm about to drop
murder and pain mixtape and then i'm
gonna come with i am my brother's keeper
uh album after that with the documentary
just keeping the foot on the gas yeah
how inspirational is it to see someone
like i swear who kind of like went to a
major label
and it
like he got out obviously i remember uh
before he got locked up you know a lot
of dope boys from detroit are in a z so
when i be dj in the clubs i play like my
song like money phone [ __ ] like that
but then he got locked up
came out the motown thing was probably
detrimental to his career even though it
should have been they didn't know what
they were doing
but like since he got off that label
he's really kind of put his head down
and um
just been on his [ __ ] like it's it's
real it's real dope i think it really i
think it is it's it's definitely you
know i'm saying a good thing to see that
man dude he do because it's like and i
think viz learned more when veg went to
jail
when vest was able to have that time to
himself you know and
reality check to see who really with you
and all that because we don't have we
don't have talks about this [ __ ] and
it's like you know what i'm saying once
he did that and he came out he was like
he was better than ever even with the
label trying to do that
and then he he going his own way he went
bigger because he had a vision you know
what i'm saying and it was just tunnel
vision like you guys realize man vs like
i'll be i've been in the game what seven
eight years and i'd be like bro i ain't
where i want to be you know what i'm
saying and i look at [ __ ] like
viz like veg's been in the game when i
was in high school you know and he just
now i'm getting his real push you know
what i'm saying
it's like bro don't ever quit don't ever
quit don't ever give up bro because the
day that you quit you might had your
breakthrough you know what i'm saying so
you got to keep that [ __ ] pushing and he
he really like a motivation for real
like my first mixtape you know what i'm
saying this was posting my [ __ ] pulled
up to the studio or that as a when i was
a young [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
when i was with my producer aunt beast
and it's just like
at that level like you know what i'm
saying you don't have to do that bro and
he bears always show love to the [ __ ]
bro from the jump the whole east so the
rest of the year we're getting two more
projects yeah y'all know y'all getting
more than that man i'm dropping every
[ __ ] week every week every
monday wednesday depends on what day i'm
feeling i'm feeling i'm dropping at
least a video or a song you know what
i'm saying and that's one thing that i
had to get back doing because it's like
one thing about snap i stay consistent
no matter what you always see me
somewhere moving though you always see
me on the internet dropping something
and that two year break i kind of slowed
down so it's like at the end of the day
it's so many [ __ ] rappers we dealing
with not age like everybody everybody
waking up rapping and everybody don't
get me wrong it's a lot of telling out
here so you could in competition with a
lot of people so who who the [ __ ] you
think you is to drop once or twice and
think you about to get somewhere hey i
know when you got [ __ ] like gucci you
was dropping mixtapes
back to back and it's like bro you in
you're in a competition with a lot of
people so it's like you got to realize
people got to grow they got to grow it
listening to your sound like and that's
the thing about music like music is so
creative not you ain't gotta be no buff
about rappers you know what i'm saying
be creative with your [ __ ] and let them
it's a crowd out there that's gonna
understand your music yeah i just think
you gotta relate to people man yeah once
you relate to [ __ ] it's like
that's how i am now like [ __ ]
like oh you yell all the time so i'm
like at first i used to get mad i got me
[ __ ] up but then
i'm like nah let me kind of lower down a
little bit and see and it actually
worked it actually worked like you got
some [ __ ] fans who just like
snapped we want to hear you turn yeah
then you got some fans that's like oh
man i can ride to this [ __ ] bro i see
the growth in you because my fans they
grow with me they see me from
no [ __ ] change to change to
[ __ ] sitting on the block with
guns to doing [ __ ] videos out here in
l.a and all they seeing the growth in me
and it's like i'm at a point like right
now like
features i do features i got i got i got
man i got some of the biggest features
in the [ __ ] world like some of the
biggest artists right now i got features
with and it's like at the end of the day
feature ain't gonna do it for me
it's me that's gonna do it for me
because the people want to hear me you
know what i'm saying that yeah the
future is good but at the end of the day
i got time to be chasing no [ __ ] around
getting unclear you know even though i
never had that problem but right now i'm
really
confident in my music now back then when
i was rapping my [ __ ] would be like
yeah yo [ __ ] i really was like
it's cool
cool nah i'd be like man you got me
[ __ ] up this is real this real music
right here bro like i'm making real
music and it's timeless music now you
know what i'm saying i ain't scared to
talk about certain [ __ ] i ain't scared
to take that that route like you got
some [ __ ] who just want to talk
about like detroit detroit known for
talking about bus rolly [ __ ] hoes
don't
i'm not talking about that i'm gonna
talk about busting your [ __ ]
head you know what i'm saying oh i might
talk about some pain [ __ ]
nah i'm not a flashy rapper i talk about
yeah [ __ ] got that i get on that
depends on i match the energy like if
i'm on a song with vids like we might go
back and forth talking [ __ ] and drill
[ __ ] right you know what i'm saying on
the song with peasy i might just come
straight on my shmoo
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying on the
song with [ __ ] like savings if
he wasn't like a king vine now i'm about
to get on my snap [ __ ]
so that's how that's how it is a lot of
people ain't think i can do that when
they get in studio they think they got
to make it a key or drill something i'm
like yeah nah [ __ ]
you can do it i can do anything i can do
it [ __ ] i love rock and roll like i
[ __ ] with rock and roll nickelback
lincoln park all day like jesus
nickelback's terrible [ __ ] what your
[ __ ] [ __ ] back man you dripping bro
you trippin you don't [ __ ] with him man
backs got some [ __ ] hits you know but
like
they're just like it's kind of like
nickelback is like the um
what's like a very generic like pop
rapper that like nickelback's like the
flowrider of rock and roll okay okay
yeah yeah man i get what you're saying
nah i get what you said lowriders like
yeah he's got hits you know but like
yeah
yeah you know what i know the songs yeah
yeah but i'm not like bumping the flow
rider album facts yeah definitely the
rockstar more for the [ __ ] not
to get them views bro they do that's the
crowd well i appreciate you pulling up
man we're gonna do a freestyle too so
next video check that out oh yeah man
let's get it man you got the king energy
in this [ __ ] we sliding gliding
son now guns are you scared that your
[ __ ] ass in the house man we bout to
turn up on this freestyle and guess what
it's the first freestyle ever that i
ever did well [ __ ]